Mamadou kamara's brother was shot dead
by the police in 2018. this charity
football tournament has been held in gay
camara's honor in the years since
eight police bullets hit Gay's car when
he was caught up in a sting operation
targeting a stolen car next to his in a
Northern Paris suburb no police officer
was ever charged in connection with his
death
we won't get Justice for guy in France
we've exhausted all the appeals and
they've refused everything they refused
to share the surveillance footage
refusing to cooperate can lead to death
here and the police will never be
condemned
young men here come from the sort of
low-income towns and suburbs where they
say police and community relations seem
to be driven more by confrontation than
cooperation the French police aren't
behaving properly they mistreat the
youth especially the youth from the
suburbs they make blunders always check
the same people's ID and speak badly to
them they insulted me once they told me
talk well shut up you fool
I didn't expect this it started with the
tragic death of a kid and turned into
looting and Shop robberies they're
hurting themselves they're hurting the
population who's innocent there are
other ways to get your voice heard
Mamadou understands the frustrations of
people angry at the shooting of nihil in
non-terre
y
my brother guy's death shocked all the
local residents they wanted Revolution
but I told them I can't push people to
break the law if you want to fight for
guy's death then let's organize
ourselves and find solution for our
youth however Revolution is
understandable we've been asking for
police accountability for 40 years
Francis Police Union has admitted a
breakdown of trust a spokesman blaming
government policies focusing on
Intervention and repression rather than
neighborhood policing
Emmanuel macron has postponed a state
visit to Germany to handle what has
become the worst crisis to face its
presidency since the yellow vest
protests five years ago now macron must
work out how to address the
long-standing complaints of police
violence and systematic racism in
France's low-income suburbs
Bernard Smith Al Jazeera pants